let me go straight into the CIMA for the
debate in the wake of Weinstein The
Weinstein scandal many call for a
boycott of the films of Polanski and
Woody Allen yet 20th century literary
critics encourage us to look at the text
alone are the misdeeds of writers
thinkers and artists irrelevant to the
way we look at their work or should we
excise the morally indefensible we have
a very interesting and diverse panel
this morning to my right is Stanley fish
the eminent literary critic and legal
scholar Nell Stevens who is a memoirist
and a goldsmith lecturer to my left I
have John Harvey who is a Cambridge life
fellow and an expert on visual culture
and to the very left I have MS all
Kovich who is an activist and
performance artist and I'll let Stanley
fish that my first instar instinct was
to ants to say that you cannot separate
the artists from the art because I'm an
intentional list and believe that
meaningful marks and signs are only
meaningful if one assumes that they've
been produced or designed by an
intentional being therefore the
separation of the artist from the artist
is from my point of view impossible but
then I had a second thought recalling a
colleague there was a terrible person
he was absolutely untrustworthy and
malevolent said and did horrible things
behind your back but when I invited him
into my class to explain a technical
matter that I would not have been able
to explain he bent himself to the task
in a way so pure that you could see
almost see as he began to talk that the
zeal for his subject burnt away all the
malign aspects of his personality and he
was another first
and so it occurred to me that no doubt
there were artists like that and then I
recall the TS Eliot in tradition of the
individual talent had indeed defined art
and artistry as the extinction of
personality so that the artist rather
than bringing with him in transmuting
all of the him or her and in transmuting
all the aspects of her personality
instead concentrates and focuses in the
way that my colleague did but then this
is all of but then but then I remembered
Woody Allen I
I lived part of the year in Manhattan
and as I went around the corner from my
apartment last year there was a Woody
Allen movie being made so Woody Allen is
right there
what am I to do with that and of course
you can't separate Woody Allen from
Woody Allen movies because Woody Allen
movies are all about
Woody Allen so much so that
distinguished actors and actresses like
Michael Caine and others speak in Woody
Allen tones when they appear in his
movies so I thought there must be a
distinction between authors who perform
as my colleague did and burn away all of
their moral warts and artists like Woody
Allen who make art out of them moral
warts so therefore it would be a wrong
act of critical deportment to ignore
that and then I thought there's also the
distance question
Caravaggio murdered somebody the great
English poet Ben Jonson as far as we
know murdered two people it might have
been more but when I see if Caravaggio
painting or read a Ben Jonson poem I'm
not thinking about that
apparently Robert Frost a great American
poet was also according to his
biographers one of the vilest people who
ever lived
betraying and being crude to everyone
when I read the road not taken' I don't
think of that
so that led me to another thought maybe
it's distance maybe the museum effect
kicks in and when they're dead or
hanging somewhere or part of the Harvard
library of classics you don't have to
worry about any of this stuff and then
my final thought was that perhaps his
question the question that we've been
asked here to consider is in fact
misstated because it assumes the
distinct and stable identity of both the
artist and the work of art but in the
last 40 years those assumptions have
been exploded by performance artists
like EMA by people who make art out of
garbage and then steward around the
floor by those like Robert Rauschenberg
who makes art by erasing a drawing of de
Kooning's and say and then says that
destruction is in fact the hallmark of
art so perhaps our entire panel is a
mistake after having raised this
question I find myself at the end of my
time so I won't answer it right well
thank you very much then but before we
leave I think I think that was a really
interesting introduction to this
question I come to it from a position of
studied and passionate ambivalence which
is not to say that I don't care but
rather that I feel myself to be pulled
very strongly in two different
directions one is a really personal
reaction of rage and outraged about the
disgraceful behaviors of so many
normally men two people normally two
women and I think perhaps one thing we
should lead on and semi touch on it
perhaps is its the relevance of the
personal to all of this this is a
personal question to a lot of people and
to most women it brings up a lot of
memories and trauma and that
we can't lose sight of that when we talk
about this in an academic tone the other
of pull to my attention and an opinion
is a rejection of absolutes and in a
real discomfort with I think a perceived
lack of nuance in the conversation when
we talk about boycotting or cutting out
certain artists from art from our Canon
so I'm just going to use this time to
quickly dig into a few of those
potential difficulties or nuances or
hypocrisy the first is to highlight who
we are willing to offer to this
conversation and whether or not we can
separate the art in the artists we it
comes back over and over again to Woody
Allen we're very interested in trying
trying to see whether we can possibly
separate the art from the artist when
the artist happens to be a rich white
man we are far less interested in having
that conversation about Junot Diaz with
Dominican American writer or show me
Alexei a Native American writer the
people who are being punished for this
most severely tend not to be the most
powerful people and that is something I
think we have to stay aware of when we
talk about these things and the other
question I have is what our goal is when
we decide we cannot separate the art
from the artist when we talk about
boycotts in other situations are the
contexts we tend to have a financial
goal the goal is to harm someone
financially by not buying their product
in which case you would think that this
conversation would end upon the death of
the artist but if we look at someone
like Naipaul who recently died his death
was really the beginning of a whole lot
of conversations about whether or not we
can accept him and that's not going to
if we don't buy an iPod work it no
longer harms a dead man so what we're
looking at actually is a cleansing of
the Canon and then we come back to this
question that Stanley has raised about
distance staying on Naipaul and the
parallels in the behaviors between nibel
and Charles Dickens are extraordinary
Dickens was a passionate racist he calls
for the called for the extermination of
the Indian race he was a vile misogynist
who treated women his life absolutely
appalling Lee and yet we think of him as
very cozy we cling to this Avant color
image of Dickens who created Christmas
as we know it on all of these things and
again is this really
just a question of whiteness and power
and masculinity Emily Bronte in The
Guardian recently was told we shouldn't
be reading weathering heights because
she was a difficult woman and she if
she'd been alive today she would have
been a Tory so who are we who are we
punishing when we when we enforce these
these kinds of absolutes and and is
there a chance that we can open up the
Canon in a more interesting way when we
choose to a bitter eight certain people
from it good thank you very much then we
have an hour more questions again so we
here have something to debate I will
give the worth and to John yeah thank
you we ban from our television
entertainers who abused children child
abuse is vile and a crime of course
murder is also a crime and Caravaggio
murdered someone and Ben Jonson may have
murdered someone but they weren't career
murderers whereas John Ruskin one would
have to say was a lifelong pedophile is
something I got to know more about when
I wrote a novel about John Ruskin his
wife and her lover the subject of a
portrait where I came up against Ruskin
what he called his terrible weakness he
said I am very naughty about Tiny's
that's little girls and I've less and
less hope of mending
[Applause]